[Music]
you me knew you guys know that name you
mean you you me knew i thought you were
saying a sentence wow that's racist
is she the new asian chick on sports
illustrated
yeah she's the first uh asian american
oh she's the thick girl huh yeah yeah oh
i thought she was the one on the the tv
show that was popular the games squid
games squig games oh hold on sports
illustrated yeah she's the first asian
american swimsuit cover model first this
has been going around because they're
people are like oh she's fat why is she
on there yeah people are just kind of
like some people are pretty pissed
because she's like a plus size model oh
she's pretty dude yeah she's gorgeous
look at her
i think she's i think she's like did you
say she from irvine japanese and
something like she's japanese and german
or whatever i don't know she's a black
guy's dream come true
like oh damn china thick over there
what do you think this has to do with
jordan peterson because he probably was
talking some [ __ ] about it was he
talking some [ __ ] he said she was not
beautiful
and um he saw this as another
progressive tactic to like you know
change the idea of beauty if that's not
beautiful then what kind of chicks are
he is he hooking up with i want to see
those chicks damn he has some like dope
things to say sometimes but then when he
talks about like that's not one of them
top three when he talks about this kind
of stuff i'm just like i just
don't chime in on that one because
that's what he's like there's not your
place to sit the exact quote who's
jordan peterson he's like a psychologist
right yeah professor of psychology
and he's i think a lot the public views
him as more like right leaning or
conservative even though he's not really
political i don't think but just his
views are more like
ownership type of thing and like we need
to get society back on track um but
because it's more away from like the
more liberal we're like oh we got to
help each other out uh he seems more
that way but i think he's technically
apolitical and he's very he claims to be
a classic liberal he says that he's
liberal but the spectrum went so left
yes that he they throw him in the right
now usually goes against a lot of like
progress like far progressive left stuff
like
he combats it pretty hard yeah so he
says um this is his tweet
sorry not beautiful and no amount of
authoritarian tolerance is going to
change that
even that picture i posted is really
pretty
she's like doing a west side something
like that if it's not your type this is
not your time exactly like that's a wild
tape that's very subjective right
exactly i think it's just the fact that
she's like a plus size and it's not like
you know conventionally healthy
i think it's like they're this whole
movement right now where like victoria's
secret was forced to do plus size models
and like they don't want to say they
were forced but yeah
they were persuaded
that's basically what's happening right
it's like you can't have a look anymore
or like it's it's gotta be like all
right you gotta you gotta have the plus
size girls you gotta have whatever and
then i'm all for like yo man different
strokes for different folks yeah but
then there's the other side of it too
where it's kind of like the king with
the invisible clothing everyone's just
like propping them up like oh you're so
hot you're so hot
but
i don't really know right like um
like statistics wise like how many men
find overweight women attractive like
there are chubby chasers and it exists
it's not even overweight though but like
i'm not talking about her exactly i'm
just talking about the whole
argument right like the it's happening
right now where like people are like
just just kind of like
saying like oh this is this you know
even like um putting um obese women on
on on on a fit things and saying that's
healthy yeah something that's even new
too if you go like nike.com they have
plus size models for both guys and girls
yeah which that wasn't a thing back in
like 2017 or something but my question
though is okay
she's a little thicker than i expected
she's still beautiful
but does she play sports to be on this
cover
no well the sports illustrated models
are never into sports really
so notoriously for sports illustrated
they're like high-end uh swimsuit models
that they get on the cover of sports
doesn't play ping-pong or anything no
none of them are like because when you
think sports if illustrated you think
they're athletes
a lot of times they do put athletes on
there too though right they have them
they'll have them but the traditional
when you think of like the the really
famous ones i think i don't know if
heidi klum was one of them but there's
like
the though there's like a whole name
there's like a a category of v sports
illustrated models those ones aren't uh
professional athletes but they do have
ones that are also beautiful it looks
like let's say someone that plays soccer
and they'll get her like to pose like in
a taste soccer ball yeah like a tasteful
sexy way or whatever nude not a tasteful
thing but naked
does sports illustrated do like the nude
edition where they get like male and
female athletes
admire like the athletic body or
whatever i think like um
beauty is subjective right it just
depends on culture and what you find
attractive and whatever yeah but i think
like um what i don't like with this
whole movement is um
they're kind of enabling obesity and
they're saying that's okay and that's
healthy and all that and i'm like
is it though because each end of the
spectrum is very unhealthy like whether
you're too skinny like a super bowl that
never [ __ ] eats or whatever and then
if you're too big
that you get i mean i'm not even like
big but when i when i gain weight like i
get sleep apnea i get health problems
and like i'm just like damn dude that's
a [ __ ]
definite road to diabetes and all that
[ __ ] yeah so i don't know but that that
but there's but that's they're starting
to make that look like
oh that's cool that's healthy that's fit
but it's not and i think that's
different from yeah calling someone
beautiful that's fine because like you
just don't know like depending on
culture there's just different style
different tastes right so that's
different i think beauty because even
like attractiveness is different right
because it's also subjective
and then like um but there used to be an
epitome like the epitome of what a
physical fit like best female beautiful
female they used to look at it like oh
these models it was only that and i'm
like i get that they're changing it now
to like okay
if you want to be the definition of
beautiful you have different options
sure but that's different from healthy
yeah i think healthy is a different
thing that's a good talk i agree with
that but i do like how when like you're
saying like these sites have like plus
size like
because like i'm a bigger dude so like
now i get to see people wearing it i'm
like oh that's more like what it's going
to fit like me not some really thin guy
that i'm like that's obviously not going
to look like that when i wear that and
also too is like you could be healthy at
any size yeah right it's just like you
could be a bigger dude a bigger woman
and as long as you exercise pretty
regularly and you eat you get pretty
refined maybe buff it unhealthy yeah
exactly like you could like be healthy
right
[Laughter]
you could still be relatively healthy
allergies but then at that point then
it's like a body fat thing that's what
that's like for a lot of people they say
like oh you're fat but it's like that's
a body fat issue rather than a health
issue those are separate things and we
need to make the distinguishing factor
because the definition of health is not
it's very different it's very like broad
like
and everyone's metrics of health is
always changing that's true right and
like depending on who you talk to this
is healthy this is unhealthy one thing
that i really didn't like and i couldn't
get behind was uh the responses to
jordan peterson about like people saying
how dare you like how how dare men judge
women for beauty she's on the [ __ ]
cover of sports illustrated
what are you supposed to do like how
dare you for me i'm like i think she's
beautiful right yeah but i also if uh
respect free speech
so i'm like if jordan doesn't think
she's beautiful he also has every right
to say whatever the hell he wants
you know it's a back and forth because
people will talk [ __ ] to him
you're missing out man this is yeah or
for the rest of us that like that kind
of stuff here's also what i think is a
problem that no one's talking about
whether it's plus size or minus size all
models
they all have really pretty faces and i
think that's faces oh
what about people with bad faces why
aren't about people with unsymmetrical
faces look at her look at her gorgeous
perfect face yeah and her and her nice
nose and stuff
yeah perfect jawline and stuff i spoke
with somebody and there was a doctor
that would assess your face and he would
fix your face to make it so that you're
more likable he's he broke down
scientifically features on a face that
make you more likeable to other people
what is it
symmetry right yeah symmetry your nose
your eyebrow shelf thingymajiggers your
cheekbones your jaw oh probably bigger
eyes too because they said dog oh i'm
good
make your most likeable face right now
i didn't i did no because they even said
uh dogs have evolved uh by being like
the humans companion to have more baby
shaped eyes because they're more
expressive so if you look at a wolf like
it's more beady it's small and then the
dogs now they're like big like almost
like a deer like bambi right so the
beadier the eyes the bad the badder they
are
very bad
some groups would like this theory
i think all people are bad at their eyes
look like this
i just feel like we're so past like
getting mad at people for or getting mad
at men for judging women on a cover like
this it's like
if you said oh she's freaking hot
everyone goes yeah if you said i don't
think so don't judge women but it's both
judging
yeah it's judging either way saying
someone's hot or not is still judging
whether it's a blue ribbon first place
prize the whole idea is kind of messed
up it seems like he's making about the
progressive stuff right like right which
is like okay just say that then yeah you
know lead with that instead of being
like not pretty or whatever like
that's just rude
yeah you're just being a dick and i
think that's where the clapback comes
from right because like i listen to
jordan peterson every now and then and i
like some of the stuff that he has to
say but when he goes out he goes not
pretty yeah i'm like hey man leave her
alone dude what about this what about
this what about uh what about when
there's a fight that's happening yeah
and then like another fighter that's
watching that fight they go snooze
faster
in this day and age with so much content
everywhere how could you get mad at
anyone for judging anything everything's
up for judgment that's everything if it
goes out there it's up for you
i don't i don't like to tweet i would
prefer a reaction video
jordan peterson reacts no words just
he backtrack and say some [ __ ] like oh
that was just a social experiment bro
why are you mad i don't know but he but
he definitely uh is taking a break from
twitter because of the backlash of this
damn i mean you call somebody ugly like
that's kind of mean and it's like her
first it's her first [ __ ] you know
magic thing to be proud of yeah right
it's like there's so many good positive
things you're [ __ ] on our parade
yeah you're just gonna go not my thing
not beautiful like dude come on he
doesn't like trying to thick man you
don't like trying to think dude
what if this whole time he wasn't even
talking about her way he was just
talking about asian girls
and then he's all like
yeah chinese don't like never scroll
down so he's like wait she's big
i just said
i saw those eyes and i was like that
[ __ ] chinese girl on sports
illustrated
elon musk when he's like i should should
i buy sports illegitimate so she never
has to be on the cover again
[Music]
you